3.5 got the pep 484 type hints what is
Type hinting and is it used by The
Interpreter the hints or is it just
syntactic sugar so the type hints is an
optional mechanism that people can use
and it's especially popular with sort of
larger companies that have very large
code bases written in Python do you
think of it as almost like documentation
saying these two variables are this type
more than documentation I mean so it
it is a sub language of python where
where you can express the types of
variables so here's a variable and it's
an integer and here's an argument to
this function and it's a string and here
is a function that returns a list of
strings but that's not checked when you
run the code but
exactly there there is a separate piece
of software called a static type Checker
that reads all your source code without
executing it and things long and hard
about
what it looks from just reading the code
that code might be doing
and double checks if that makes sense if
you take the types as annotated into
account so this is something you're
supposed to run as you develop it's like
a linter yeah it does definitely a
development tool but the type
annotations currently are not used for
uh speeding up The Interpreter and there
are a number of reasons
many people don't use them
even when they do use them uh they
sometimes contain lies where the static
type Checker says everything's fine
I cannot prove that this integer is ever
not an integer but at runtime somehow
someone manages to violate that
assumption
and The Interpreter
ends up doing just fine if we started
enforcing type annotations in Python
many python programs would no longer
work
and some python programs wouldn't even
be possible because they're too dynamic
and so we made we made a choice of not
using the annotations there there is a
possible future where eventually
three four five releases in the future
we could start using those annotations
to sort of
provide hints because we can we can
still say well the source code leads us
to believe that these X and Y are both
integers and so we can generate an add
an add integer instruction
but we can still have a fallback that
says
oh if the if somehow the code code at
runtime provided something else maybe it
provided two decimal numbers
we can still use that generic ad
operation as a fallback but we're not
there is there currently a mechanism or
do you see something like that where you
can almost add like an assert
inside a function that says please check
that my type hints are actually mapping
to reality sort of like insert manual
static typing there are third-party
libraries that uh are in that business
so it's possible to do that kind of
thing it's possible to for a third party
library to take a hint
and enforce it it seems like a tricky
thing what what well what we actually do
is and this I think this is a fairly
unique feature in Python the type hints
can be introspected at runtime so while
the program is running
they mean python is a very
introspectable language you can look at
a variable and ask yourself what did
what is the type of this this variable
and if that baby that variable happens
to refer to a function you can ask what
are the arguments to the function
and nowadays you can also ask what are
the type annotations for the function so
the type annotations are there inside
the variable as it's at runtime they're
mostly associated with the function
object not with each individual variable
but uh right you can sort of map from
from the arguments to the variables and
that's what a third-party Library can
have exactly and the problem with that
is that all that extra runtime type
checking
uh is going to slow your code down
instead of speed it up I think uh to
reference this uh sales pitchy blog post
that says 75 of developers haven't spent
on debugging I would say that in some
cases that might be okay it might be
okay to pay the cost of performance
for the catching of the types the type
errors
and in most cases doing it
statically before you ship your code to
production is more efficient than doing
it at runtime piecemeal yeah can you
tell me about
m-y-p-y my pie project
what is it what's the mission and in
general what is the future of static
typing in Python
well so my pie uh was started by a
Finnish uh developer ukulele
so many cool things out of Finland I
gotta say just that part of the world I
guess people have nothing better to do
in those long cold Winters
yeah I don't know I think Yuka lived in
England when he invented uh that stuff
actually but my pie is the original
static type checker for Python and the
the type annotations that were
introduced with pep 484
were sort of developed
together with the the static type
Checker and in fact Yuka had first
invented a different syntax that wasn't
quite compatible with python
and uh yukai and I sort of met at the
python conference in I think in 2013
and we we sort of came up with a
compromise syntax
that would not require any changes to
python
and that would let my pie sort of be an
ad on static type checker for python
just out of curiosity was it like double
colon or something what was he proposing
that would break python I think he was
using angular brackets for uh types like
in C plus plus or uh Java generics yeah
you can't use angular brackets in Python
it would be too tricky
for attempt well we the the key thing is
that we already had uh you know a Syntax
for annotations we just didn't know what
to use them for yet
so type annotations were just the sort
of most logical thing to to use that
existing dummy Syntax for
so there was no there was no Syntax for
uh defining generics
directly syntactically in the language
my pie literally meant my version of
python where my refers to Yuka
he had a parser that translated my pie
into python by like doing the type
checks
and then removing the annotations and
all the angular brackets from the
positions where where he was using them
but a preprocessor model doesn't work
very well with the typical workflow of
uh python development projects that's
funny I mean that could have been
another major split if it became
successful like if you watch typescript
versus JavaScript
is it like a split in the community over
types right that seems to be stabilizing
now it's not necessarily a split there
are certainly plenty of people who don't
use typescript but
just use the original JavaScript
notation just like there are many people
in the python world who don't use type
annotations and don't use static type
Checkers now I know but there is a bit
of a split between typescript and
JavaScript old school JavaScript AES
whatever well in the JavaScript world
transpilers are sort of the standard way
of working anyway which is why
typescript being a transpiler itself is
not a big deal
and transpires for people who don't know
it's what's the exactly the thing you
said with my pies it's the code I guess
you call it pre-processing code that
translates from one language to the
other and that's part of the culture
part of the workflow of the JavaScript
community so that's right at the same
time
an interesting development in the
JavaScript slash typescript world at the
moment is that
there is a proposal under consideration
it's only a stage one proposal
that proposes to add a feature to
JavaScript where just like python it
will ignore certain syntax
when running the JavaScript code
and what it ignores is more or less a
superset of The typescript annotation
syntax
interesting so that would mean that
eventually if you wanted to you could
take typescript
uh and you could shove it directly into
a JavaScript interpreter without
transplation
the interesting thing in the JavaScript
world at least the web browser world
the web browsers have changed how they
deploy and uh they they sort of update
their JavaScript engines
much more quickly than they used to in
the the early days and so there's much
less of a need for
translation in JavaScript itself because
most browsers just support the most
recent version of ecmascript just on a
tangent of a tangent do you see if you
will recommend somebody use a thing
would you recommend typescript or
JavaScript
I would recommend a typescript just
because of the strictness of the typing
it's an enormously helpful extra tool
that helps you sort of
keep your head straight about what your
code is actually doing
I mean it's it's it it helps with
editing your code it helps with ensuring
that your code
is not too incorrect
and it's actually
quite compatible with JavaScript never
mind this syntactic sort of hack that is
still years in the future
but any library that is written in pure
JavaScript can still be used from
typescript programs and also the other
way around you can write a library in
typescript and then export it in a form
that is totally consumable by JavaScript
that sort of compatibility is is sort of
the key to this to the success of
typescript
yeah just to look at it as almost like a
biological system that's evolving it's
fascinating to see JavaScript evolve the
way it does well maybe we should
consider that biological systems are
just the Engineering Systems too right
yes but very Advanced with more history
but it's almost like the most visceral
in the JavaScript world because there's
just so much code written in JavaScript
that for its history was messy if you
talk about bugs per line of code I just
feel like JavaScript
eats the cake or whatever the
terminology is it beats python by a lot
in terms of number of bugs meaning like
way more bugs in JavaScript and then and
then the obviously the browsers the
developing just there's so much active
development it feels a lot more like
Evolution where a bunch of stuff is born
and dies and there's experimentation and
debates versus python is more
um all that stuff is happening but
there's just a longer history of stable
working giant software systems written
in python versus JavaScript is just a
giant beautiful I would say mess of code
it's very different culture and
to some extent differences in culture
are random but to some extent they the
differences have to do with the
environment yeah uh and the fact that
JavaScript is primarily
the language for uh developing web
applications especially the client side
and the fact that it's basically the
only language for developing web
applications
makes that Community sort of just have a
different nature than the community of
other languages
plus the graphical component
um and the fact that they're deploying
it on all kinds of uh shapes of screens
and devices and all that kind of stuff
it just creates a beautiful chaos anyway
back to Mifi
so what okay you you met you talked
about a syntax that could work
where does it currently stand
what's the future of static typing in
Python
it is still controversial but it is much
more accepted than when my pi and pep
484 were were young
what's the connection between uh pep 484
type hints and my pie my pie
was the original static type Checker so
it might buy quickly evolved from yuka's
own variant of python to a static type
checker for Python and uh sort of Pep
484 that that was it like
a very productive year where like many
hundreds of messages were exchanged
debating that merits
of every aspect of of that pep
and so my pie is a static type checker
for python it is itself written in
Python
most
additional static typing features that
we introduced in the time since three
six
uh we're also prototyped through my pie
my pie being an open source project with
a very small number of maintainers
it was successful enough that people
said the aesthetic type checking stuff
for python is actually worth an
investment for our company
nice but
somehow they chose not to support
making my pie faster say or adding new
features to my Pi but both Google and
Facebook and later Microsoft developed
their own static type Checker I think
Facebook was one of the first
they decided that they wanted to use the
same technology that they had
successfully used for hhvm
because they they sort of they had a
bunch of compiler writers and and sort
of static type checking experts who had
written the hhvm compiler and it was a
big success within the company
and they had done it in a certain way
sort of
they wrote a big highly parallel
application in an obscure language named
o camel which is apparently mostly very
good for a writing static type checkers
interesting yeah I have a lot of
questions about how to write a static
type Checker then that's very confusing
Facebook wrote their version and they've
worked on it in secret for about a year
and then they came clean and went open
source
uh Google in the meantime was developing
something called Pi type which was
mostly
interesting because it as you may have
heard they have one gigantic mono repo
so all the code is checked into a single
repository Facebook has a different
approach so Facebook developed pyre
which which was written in O camel which
worked well with Facebook's development
workflow
and Google developed something they call
Pi type which was actually itself
written in Python
uh and it was meant to sort of fit well
in
their static type checking needs in
Google's gigantic mono repo so Google
wasn't one giant got it so the just to
clarify this static type checker
philosophically is a thing that's
supposed to exist outside of the
language itself and it's just a workflow
like a debugger for the winter for
people who don't know a linter maybe you
can correct me but it it's a thing that
runs through the code continuously
pre-processing to find issues based on
style documentation I mean there's all
kinds of linters right you can check
that what usual things does a launcher
do maybe check that you haven't too many
characters in a single line linters
often do static analysis where they try
to point out things that are likely
mistakes but not incorrect according to
the language specification like maybe
you have a variable that you never use
for the compiler that is valid you might
sort of you might be planning to use it
in future version of the of the code and
the compiler might just optimize it out
but the compiler is not going to tell
you hey you're never using this variable
a linter will tell you that variable is
not used maybe there's a typo somewhere
else where you meant to use it but you
accidentally use something else or there
are a number of sort of common scenarios
and A linter is often
a a big collection of little heuristics
where by looking at the combination of
how your code is laid out maybe how it's
indented maybe the comment structure
uh but also just
things like definition of names use of
names
it'll tell you likely things that are
wrong and in some cases linters are are
really style checkers
uh for python there are a number of
linters that check things like
do you use the the pep 8
recommended naming scheme for your
functions and classes and variables
because like classes start with an
uppercase and the rest starts with a
lowercase and
there's like differences there and so
the linter can tell you hey you have a
class that uh whose first letter is not
an uppercase letter and that's just I
just find it annoying if I wanted that
to be an uppercase letter I I would have
typed an uppercase letter but other
people find it very comforting that if
the linter
is no longer complaining about their
code that they have followed all the
style rules maybe it's a fast way for a
new developer joining a team to learn
the style rules right yeah there's
definitely that but the best use of
linter is probably
not so much to to sort of
enforce team uniformity but to actually
help Developers
catch bugs that the compilers for
whatever reason don't catch
and there's lots of that in Python and
so uh but a static type checker
focuses on a particular aspect of the
linting which
I mean it might probably doesn't care
how you name your classes and variables
uh
but it is meticulous about when you say
that there was an integer here and
you're passing a string there it will
tell you hey that string is not an
integer so something's wrong either
either you're incorrect when you said it
was an integer or you're incorrect when
you're passing into string if this is a
race of static type Checkers is somebody
winning as you said it's interesting
that the companies didn't choose to
invest in this uh centralized
development of my pie is is there a
future for my pi
what do you see as the oh well one of
the companies went out and everybody
uses like uh Pi type whatever Google's
is called well Microsoft is hoping that
uh Microsoft's horse in that race called
pyrite is going to win by right right
like r i g h d correct yeah my my all my
word processors tend to typo correct
that as pyrite the name of the I don't
know what it is
some kind of semi-precious metal all
right
I love it okay so okay that's the
Microsoft hope but it okay so let me ask
the question a different way is there
going to be ever a future whereas the
static type Checker gets integrated into
the language
nobody is currently excited about
doing any work towards that that doesn't
mean that five or ten years from now
the situation isn't different
uh
at the moment
all the static type checkers
uh still evolve at a much higher speed
than Python and its annotation syntax
evolve you get a new release of python
once a year those are the only times
that you can introduce new annotation
syntax and there's there are always
people who invent new new annotation
syntax that they're trying to push
uh and worse
once we've all agreed that we are going
to put some new syntax in we can never
take it back
at least a sort of deprecating an
existing feature takes many releases
because you'd have to assume that people
started using it as soon as we announced
it
and then you can't take it away from
them right away you have to start
telling them well this will go away but
we're not gonna commit tell you that
it's an error yet and then later it's
going to be a warning and then
eventually three releases in the future
maybe we remove it
on the other hand the typical static
type checker
still has a release like
every month every two months certainly
many times a year
some type Checkers also include a bunch
of
experimental ideas that aren't official
standard python syntax yet yeah uh the
static type Checkers also just get
better at discovering
things that that sort of are unspecified
by the language but that sort of could
make sense and so each static type
Checker actually has its sort of strong
and weak points so it's cool it's like a
laboratory of experiments yep Microsoft
Google and all and you get to see and
you see that everywhere right because
there's not one single uh JavaScript in
engine either there is one in Chrome
there is one in Safari there's one in
Firefox
but that said you said there's not
interest I think there is a lot of
interest in type hinting right
um in the pep 484. actually like how
many people use that do you have a sense
how many people use because it's
optional it's the sugar I can't put a
number on it but
from the number of packages that do
interesting things with it at runtime
and the fact that there are like
now three or four very mature type
checkers
that each have their their segment of
the market and oh and then there is a
pie charm which has a sort of more
heuristic based type Checker that also
supports the same syntax
my assumption is that
many many people developing python
software professionally
for some kind of
production situation are using a static
type checker
especially any anybody who has a
continuous integration cycle
probably has a
one of the steps in in there their
testing routine that that happens for
basically every every commit
uh is run a static type checker and in
most in most cases that will be my pie
so I think it's pretty popular topic
according to this webpage
20 to 30 percent of Python 3 code bases
are using type hints
wow I wonder how they measured that did
they just scan all of GitHub
yeah that's what it looks like yeah they
did a quick setting out all of but like
a random sampling